hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today for the first time
in a long long while will actually be
covering a series that isn't hunter
hunter never fear though because there
is a metric ton of that content coming
up soon but for today I wanted to talk
about my experience with Joe Joe
now JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is one of
those things that countless amounts of
people have always been trying to get me
to read or watch for I feel like about
as long as I can remember
but I've always been kind of put off by
what I've seen from and out of context
and let's be real some of the extreme
fans out there do get a bit much but
that said the time has finally come
and I stand before you here today having
engulfed three parts of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure and I never thought I'd be
saying this but you got me I am pretty
much 100% converted into this crazy
flamboyant and surprisingly often dog
murdering world my god do I feel bad for
every single dog and Jojo because as
soon as one appears its fate is as good
as done but overall I'd like to say that
I very much enjoyed my time with Jojo
thus far although it has been very ants
it's called a unique experience I guess
and actually you know what for some
background I should say that this is not
the first time I've seriously tried to
give Jojo a go because over the years
I've actually tried to get into this
series three times prior to this I've
tried reading the manga twice and I've
tried watching the David Production
anime series once before and every
single time I was just bored to death by
part one and people had warned me about
phantom blood and how you just kind of
need to slog through it but at times I
found it to be such a very very painful
experience now granted this part of the
story was first published in what the
late 1980s somewhere around there so
more than thirty years ago and as much
as I should not expect it to stand up to
modern storytelling that is the
unfortunate reality of someone trying to
start JoJo's Bizarre Adventure in 2020
the comparison is always going to be
there oh and you know what I should
actually say before I go any further
that this video is almost certainly
going to contain spoilers from the first
three parts of Jojo
so if you're keen on getting into the
series and doing it blind then this is
where you you might want to stop
watching this but if you have seen or
read it up simply don't care and let's
continue I guess to me phantom blood
just doesn't seem like it knows what it
wants to be it's sort of a mixture
between pure horror a campy comedy and a
classic revenge quest but neither one of
those three elements are implemented
properly in any way shape or form in my
and in fact they all come to clash with
each other quite significantly leaving
me with what I felt was a pile of
undeveloped jo-jo news which is why I've
always stopped reading or watching at
some point during this part because I
just get sick of being fed said ooze and
that isn't to say that all the phantom
blood is bad it definitely has its
moments and it has its characters like I
really enjoyed baron zeppeli he has a
cool design and he was the catalyst for
introducing home on which is by far the
most interesting aspect to part one as
well as the least interesting aspect of
pots 2 & 3 but it was something here
something very slowly needed and of
course you can't go past characters like
do SP dragon either but I have had a lot
of people tell me that you can just you
know go ahead and skip part one but I'm
really glad I didn't and I don't think
you should
that's because from a storytelling
perspective there's nothing wrong with
it
it's a competent piece I think it's just
aged terribly and it feels very flat
compared to almost any manga that the
modern day will produce almost anything
there are definitely exceptions to that
but I find the idea of skipping it to be
ridiculous because it completely sets up
the groundwork of pot 2 as well as the
major antagonist of part 3 and it gives
you that very first Jojo connection with
Jonathan who as much as I dislike him as
a protagonist I have to admit does feel
quite nice when you move to Jotaro and
you can really feel that Joestar legacy
behind him I do dislike Jonathan though
because he's simply boring and really
actually depressing to watch this man is
one of the most unfortunate human beings
to have ever existed and it can be
genuine torture to just sit there and
watch him suffer repeatedly I mean the
only good thing that actually happens to
Jonathan is that he gets married and
then immediately after he gets guilt
such a depressing existence and he
doesn't have a love depth of character
either at least not from what I
experienced he's a classical gentleman
and while that's admirable and Noble
it's a bit boring as hell which is why
when for the first time I got past part
one and met a young Joseph Joestar I was
beyond relieved Joseph seemed like the
polar opposite of Jonathan he's loud
brash and a bit of a dick who needs to
be put in his place from time to time
but there we go something we can work
towards and a person we can have fun
with along the way and with that we're
now in part two and I have to say that I
really enjoyed battle tendency from the
bits and pieces I've heard from other
fans this also seems to be a fairly
disliked part of Georgia and I can only
guess that that's because it occurs
before the introduction of stands and
such but I loved it
now I am willing to accept the
possibility that I only loved it so much
because I was directly comparing it to
and blood at the time but part two took
that weed group of ideas and techniques
of part one and actually molded it into
a great product for example there was a
lot of Camp eNOS in part one but it all
seemed to be a bit subconscious and
almost unintentional meanwhile part two
took that flamboyancy to the extreme and
it's really fascinating to see all the
crazy poses that Eric he can come up
with and all around it just generated
this nice layer of levity that was not
present in part one battle tendency also
decided to begin exiting the horror
genre which made things into more of an
ancient mystery building upon the stone
mask stuff and introducing The Pillowman
who were all fantastic and we're really
intriguing figures to follow throughout
part two but the best aspect of all of
it is the whole bromance between Caesar
and Joseph especially Caesar because he
gave us a really fun character to follow
who wasn't Joseph and added a lot of
depth to the series as a result and it
was genuinely heartbreaking when he met
his bubbly demise so in the end I found
part two to be a really solid piece of
story with very compelling characters
that built on the legacy of phantom
blood and left us with a lot of promise
for Stardust Crusaders which I began
immediately afterwards and the mixed
feelings here very much continued
because part three has a lot that I love
and some that I really don't and given
that it was such a radical departure
from everything that was Jojo at this
point I think that's only to be expected
as for what I loved let's start with
almost literally every character I feel
like by this point Archie has a really
super solid mind for designing
compelling figures and the entire main
to a group at each fantastic in their
own way Jotaro is definitely my favorite
Jojo at this point in time based on
design alone because what about us but
what I will say is that I do wish we'd
gotten to know him a bit better and I
suppose to contrast Joseph and Jonathan
Jotaro got the more introverted
delinquent personality which I did
really enjoy but that naturally kind of
pushes him into the background for most
situations until it was time to bust out
star platinum and punch them dudes but
to be perfectly honest with you I feel
like a lot of Part three could just be
renamed Palmeiras bizarre adventure you
guys looking back on it he got so much
more time to shine than Joe Terra did
and he actually had this incredible
character Rock involving his sister
Abdul and even Iggy who surprised the
prize is a dog who dies
thanks a lot for that again Turkey but
to me polnareff is the undisputed star
of Stardust Crusaders he has this
perfect combination of wacky comedy
gut-wrenching drama and fantastic action
that just makes him this weird
all-rounder you get so much more of the
spotlight than our action
introverted protagonist now as for what
I didn't like about part three or I
guess I shouldn't say didn't like it
just took a lot of getting used to but
it was the narrative structure which
completely changed from a continuous
story to an isolated episodic format a
monster of the week sort of business and
that just wasn't what I was expecting
coming off part two so I essentially
spent the first half of Stardust
Crusaders patiently waiting for the
story to start because every episode or
two-part episode had the exact same
formula our group travels to a place a
stand user is waiting for them one of
the group will notice something weird
but won't tell anyone else because
reasons shenanigans since you and the
enemy stand user is defeated and we go
on to do that for an entire deck of
tarot cards as well as a set of Egyptian
gods and at times this format did get
really tiring for me part three actually
took me a couple of weeks to get through
because after the defeat of every stand
user I wasn't really inspired to watch
the next episode because I knew exactly
what was going to happen they were going
to spend one or two episodes in an
isolated scenario fighting yet another
stand user and this was not actually
going to change until late late into the
game but I did come to a point of
acceptance because these episodes were
genuinely enjoyable to watch once I'd
sat down and actually bothered to click
play because these characters can carry
anything and also in the second half of
the series The Sands start to become a
bit more interesting and not always so
combat focused and in fact one of my
favorite stant conflicts was with the
gambler guy who what's his name
Derby I think that's it because I really
enjoyed how stands were being applied on
such a micro scale and the drama that
was able to be generated from something
like a game of poker which was better
than almost all fights in the first half
for Stardust Crusaders as for Stan's
themselves I generally like them as they
get more and more creative I suspect
I'll come to enjoy them even more but
the first batch of enemy stands that
focused almost exclusively on combat got
kind of boring and for a while I found
myself really missing come on but by the
end of the series though I was like hum
oh but all of this wacky episodic
shenanigan read does go to serve a very
important purpose which is disarming us
for the tragic conclusion which cost the
lives of Abdul Iggy and cup Guin and in
each and every single one of these
moments I could tell that I'd really
enjoyed part three because when these
characters left us for good it felt like
my heart had been ripped out and crushed
by star platinum especially Iggy that
good boy deserved so so much better but
the final conflict between Jotaro and
Dia was pretty damn phenomenal
and every use of zihua doodle felt like
an oh [ __ ] moment in the anime and I now
truly understand that literally 50% of
memes on the Internet are related to
Jojo in some way shape or form which is
probably my biggest takeaway from this
entire experience now with that said I
do definitely plan on continuing with
parts four and five because why not
they're available I can't say right now
whether or not I'll be inspired enough
to continue reading the manga from the
other especially since I've heard that
the narrative structure stays pretty
much the same it's very much a
monster-of-the-week style of
storytelling from now until the end of
time although of course that's just what
I've heard please do feel free to let me
know if I'm wrong in the comments below
although the internet usually does that
anyway as well as if further parts are
worth reading but for now I feel like a
lot of this video is probably focused on
criticism but overall I've really
enjoyed my Jojo experience thus far it's
one hell of a unique series and I do
very much look forward to seeing where
Araki's madness goes from here just stop
killing dogs you sick sick human being
but that pretty much does it for this
rambling stream of consciousness in
response to JoJo's Bizarre Adventure if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produce in general then
please do consider donating to the new
world revue patreon because the support
of all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also help
support this channel and incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my disco server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your various thoughts on all things Jojo
this has been the new world review and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
you watching fire force by the way you
watch cricket hello dear I have bad
answers for you all around my friend I
did try to watch fire force I even did a
couple of episode reviews on it before I
realized that weekly reviews were an
awful experience to make but I fell out
of it because I don't know it just
didn't capture me the art style was
great the characters were generally fun
but it all felt a bit too standard
Chernin for me as for cricket absolutely
not
I will watch an infinity of fire force
before I sit down and have anything to
do with cricket and a lot of fellow
Australians think I'm insane for that
because it's effectively our national
sport but it's just so boring and games
can last for days and days and days and
most of the time it's just people
standing around and I don't know I'm not
a huge support person general except for
tennis the support of Kings the cricket
was never really my jam I will say that
my mum really loves it though but she
primarily uses it as a sleeping aid to
take off to noon naps in summer